hello everyone I'm here with
International Master Anna zotonski Anna
just won a beautiful game today
congratulations Anna yeah thank you how
do you feel I feel wonderful I still
cannot believe that I won this game I
was
very tired we're a child working so hard
during this game it was very like almost
like almost game I won very long game
and you had the black pieces too and I
want all my all my games with black
pieces this is something I think only
because my opponents like they're trying
to prove that white has advantage and uh
but endgame knowledge is important isn't
it it is but I don't know like I already
said an interview I have I had feelings
that I should not win the spawn and game
so easily
I think the I think the Rook end game I
think it was the broken game actually
this okay I was not had when my opponent
exchanged nice but on the other hand I
was happy too because I will not blunder
anything so because this is a game this
is just such a pleasure to play so you
can play like for so many random moves
you can place like 100 moves and you
were still much better of course you
have the beautiful tactical idea with
Rook G2 for those of you who haven't
seen your game they should definitely
check it out it's uh is that one again I
also calculated my uh all the spawn and
end game after Rook D4
so it was also just in case I calculated
yeah of course
how I I noticed that you're managing
your time pretty good you spent a lot of
time you think
I think on one move for 15 minutes
good time management I was just afraid
to go home and listen was my husband
will tell me about it yeah I think
critical moments are important again but
not just a minute I don't know I just
was I was so like shaken afraid to play
movie five I know there is a move in
such type of position fashion
recognition and you I played many
different lines in Catalan for both
colors and I know in you there is a move
before it's not like uh yeah but still
it was very scary to play Move like that
I understand well yesterday you had a
rest day can you tell us what you've
done in the rest day I met you yesterday
so I know but
I can tell you we were here on
Expedition it was very nice very
instructive about a little bit uh to
know about history I went to zoom but
you wanted to see animals I tried to buy
a toy uh a lot for Unfortunately they
didn't have it here okay but uh some
love my son loves Penguins so I bought a
t-shirt for him and something else with
penguins Ah that's nice I I always did
you tell him already or yes yes okay
picture
like during the game I was like so okay
nervous and excited and when my opponent
was also thinking for 30 minutes I was
thinking about my son about like his
pictures what he was doing today trying
to calm down yeah
and then I was like start smiling and
arbiter was like what happened why why
is she smiling yeah
interesting well it's nice it's nice to
know you're thinking about your family
no no I I was like trying this it helped
me to come down not to think because my
opponent had so many different uh yes
and after thinking for 50 minutes she
was thinking for
eign
so we should uh get rid of this myth
about chess players focusing for the
entire game only on chess sometimes
there are exception this was exception
this was for me it was the way to a
little bit come down during the game
yeah okay that sounds good tomorrow I
have a day off as well do you have any
plans for tomorrow something that
prepare yes only like preparation and
I'm like sorry I didn't answer a couple
emails and for people who I'm so sorry I
will answer tomorrow but you know what
they say you have an important
tournament forgiveness like summer
future students maybe okay okay I'm sure
they'll forgive you yes yes focus on the
tournament preparation and uh like I'm
playing
and she's there
so
very young active there and I I want to
like really take her prepare tomorrow
and against Irina in last round as well
of course that is very important it's a
good tournament you're doing great
um I know I had a talk with you at the
beginning of the tournament I won't
mention it for now but hopefully at the
end of it we can we can bring it back up
I have one more question for you Anna
Before I Let You Go could you please
tell us what is your favorite game of
yours that you played
um one with the best memories or
uh my uh probably my best uh game I
consider this is I think 2003 and I
always show this game to my students and
I think you can find it on YouTube
Somewhere I was it was a lecture in
Gibraltar I was analyzing this game and
uh I like this game it was because it
was kind of combination of tactics and
strategy bought and I had this windmill
you don't usually have wood milk usually
it's like portion recognition the idea
but in your games it's very rare So I
was very happy to like sacrifice Queen
and it was no check very simple but very
elegant and so far even it it was 20
years ago I considered this my favorite
chess game wow beautiful okay be sure to
check it out Anna thank you so much for
stopping by to talk to us I wish you
good luck have a good rest and good luck
in the last round and thank you so much